hi I'm Matt Welch with my co-author Nick
Gillespie we are both part of the coffee
generation along with Kenny Anderson and
David Bowie in the yellow suit and we
are co-authors of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America it's
ask a libertarian day it's the afternoon
caffeine section of it the next question
comes via Facebook from Brian Thompson
what does a libertarian small-l think
about the quote war on drugs unscared
quote and how do we change it I think
the first thing we need to do is get our
terminology straight it's a war on some
drugs and it's a war on a lot of other
things besides drugs such as the
Constitution such as people's right to
put in their bodies what they want and
to suffer the consequences and suffer
the highs as well or lavish the highs
the I think generally speaking
libertarian takes on the war on drugs is
that like most Wars it is absolutely
destructive war should always be a last
resort the war on drugs has been a
failure by every measure that you could
possibly throw at it and more to the
point it really does huge damage to the
basic idea that we are free and
autonomous individuals I think it's a
horrible thing politically motivated and
the one thing we know is that it's not
designed to alleviate social misery it
actually increases it what do we do
about it how do we change it I think
we're in the beginnings of the end of
the drug war I hate to sound like
william Westmoreland and Vietnam or
something but the lights at the end of
the tunnel we're seeing this with an
unprecedented number of people in in
high positions in exalted positions and
in political office saying we've got to
rethink this or we've got to change it
altogether we had 40% of Republican
candidates in the first GOP debate say
they were in favor of not just
legalizing pot but even heroin should be
legal this is a big big shift we need to
tell our stories about our casual and
responsible drug use as our colleague
Jacob solemn did in his great book
saying yes we need to make clear the
collateral damage
of the drug war through no-knock raids
the militarization of police the
shredding of the Constitution and the
destruction of our foreign policy our
foreign policy in South and Latin
America is completely dictated by by the
drug war it's bad stuff so we have to
end we have to make the case that you
know individuals have a right to screw
their lives up were to enjoy themselves
in the ways that they see fit I think
these three things really build up to a
pretty comprehensive case against the
war on drugs we live and we talk about
this a lot in the book we live at a time
where it's easier than ever to impact
politics from the outside looking in and
that's what we've seen with the war on
drugs with this sort of foot-in-the-door
of the medical marijuana movement which
is not something that Democrats assured
in through their benefit beneficence
beneficent beneficence thank you he's
English Lit major but what citizens did
on the local level said hey we want to
be able to smoke this stuff if we're a
cancer patient or if we're willing to
pretend that we're a cancer patient in
order to spoke medical marijuana and now
what we're seeing in California is that
average people are going further than
the drug policy activists had wanted to
go with proposition 19 which had a
pretty fair hearing in California and
2010 and will be on the ballot in 2012
we argue that that movement which should
rightly be a bipartisan movement because
there isn't a single sane person in this
country who thinks the drug war makes
sense or that we're winning it so there
is a solution to be had there but that
solutions going to come at the expense
of politics because politics produced
this god-awful mess
and so acting as citizens using the
internet banding together on the single
issue that the drug war is an outrage
it's completely untenable I think we
will begin to see finally beginning
hopefully in 2012 some state actually
legalizing and operating in open
defiance of the federal government
you